Celine Dion sword at Sunday's Billboard
Music Awards performing a cover of
Queens classic the show must go on
her first live TV performance since the
death of her husband Rene Angelil
the legendary singer was presented the
Billboard icon award by her son Rene
Charles his mom clearly stunned by the
surprise fought back tears I didn't
expect that Emerson sorry I don't want
to cry in front of you you make me so
happy to try to perform that song
without collapsing was big enough I
turned around and I saw my son and as a
mother I
I really through this whole process of
our new life really wanted to be so
strong
backstage celine relived the emotional
moment with ET at the end of the day one
of the most proud of is my family my
children and i see my husband through
them I have three magnificent boys but
for him to come on stage I knew it was
very hard for him and he did that for us
for his dad and for his brothers and for
me and I did really did not expect that
and and I thought I was going to make it
through the whole night without tears
and show strength and um loved one and I
just collapsed honey this one's for you
the show must go on
this is a new chapter of my life I'm not
the first woman mother and I'm not the
last one who will lose her husband it's
it's hard but my family is helping me
through it
you